[موسيقى]
الرياضه نصائب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
ترامب يصل نيويورك لمواجهه لائحه تهم
جنائيه وقانونيه واخرى متعلقه بالوثائق
السريه
وفي السياق ذاته الرئيس الجمهوري السابق
يعتبر اتهامه حمله اضطهاد تذهب بامريكا
الى الجحيم
بعد اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر من المعارك فاجنر
تؤكل سيطرتها على مركز مدينه باخموت وكييف
تكذبها
واشنطن تقترح على الاوروبيين
والاسرائيليين اتفاقا مؤقتا مع ايران يجمد
برنامجها النووي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اذا المشاهدين
خبر الساعه الان وصول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب الى نيويورك بانتظار
مثوله امام المحكمه يوم غد حيث افدت مصادر
مطلعه بانه سيبقى اليوم في برج ترامب بعد
وصوله الى نيويورك هو سيلتقي بمحاميه كما
من المتوقع ان يغادر نيويورك فور مثوله
امام المحكمه يوم غدنا الثلاثاء للعوده
الى مقر اقامته في فلوريدا وبخصوص
الترتيبات الامنيه اكد المصدر نفسه انه
سيتم التنسيق بين جهاز الخدمه السريه
وشرطه نيويورك لظهور ترامب كما انه سيكون
من مهام الشرطه السريه مرافقته الى مكتب
المدعي العام في نفس مبنى المحكمه وبمجرد
الانتهاء من الترتيبات الروتينيه كاخذ
بصمات اصابعه والصور سيتم نقل ترامب عبر
ممرات خلفيه للوصول الى قاعه المحكمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ازمات ترامب متعدده منها جنائيه ومنها
قانونيه واخرى متعلقه بوثائق السريه عثر
عليها في مقر اقامته في مرالغو بفلوريدا
ادله جديده كشفت عنها صحيفه واشنطن بوست
تظهر تعمد الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامبا تحقيق فيما يخص الوثائق السريه
الادله الجديده التي عثرت عليها وزاره
العدل الامريكيه جاءت بعدما فحص المحققون
رسائل الكترونيه واخرى هاتفيه لمساعدين
سابقين لترامب لمعرفه ما جرى خلال العام
الماضي ولفتت الصحيفه الامريكيه الى ان
الادله الجديده التي تم الوصول اليها تشير
الى ان التحقيق بات يركز اكثر على عنصر
عرقله التحقيق الفيدرالي تحضيرات نيويورك
لتوجيه التهم للرئيس السابق شملت انتشارا
امنيا كبيرا قدر بحوالي 30 الف شرطي
تربي اعود للمدينه التي تركها الطواعيه
والتي تتحضر لمحاكمه هي الاولى في التاريخ
الامريكي الاجراءات الامنيه مشدده هناك
انتشار لحوالي 30 الف شرطي في مدينه
نيويورك طبعا من المتوقع ان يستمر هذه
الوجود المكثف لهذه الشرطه حتى مغادره
الرئيس ترامب طبعا هو سيقضي الليله هنا في
ومن ثم سيمثل امام المحكمه الثلاثاء سيتم
اخذ بصماته سيكون الاجراءات قصيره نوعا ما
سيستمع الى لائحه الاتهام ويقول بانه غير
مذنب سيتجه الى مطار غواديا سيذهب الى
فلوريدا وسيخاطب الشعب الامريكي في خطاب
لانصاره ومؤيته وسيقول بانه القضيه مسيسه
وهناك ظلم كبير وسيقوم بجمع الاموال
لحملته الانتخابيه
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا في المتابعه في هذه
الساعه الان في اخبار الساعه معنا مباشره
من امام محكمه الجنايات في منهات كبير
مراسلي العربيه طلال الحاج طلال اهلا بك
معنا اذا الان في هذه اللحظات موكب دونالد
ترامب انتقل من المطار وهو باتجاهه الى
برج ترامب او ترامب تاور في نيويورك حيث
سيمضي ليلته هناك علمنا ان هناك استعدادات
كبيره جدا حول المحكمه التي سيمثل امامها
غدا عندك هناك ما الذي نترقبه اذا على
مدار الساعات المقبله طلال
ربما كان من اهم الاخبار خلال الساعات
المقبله هو قرار القاضي
باحتمال السماح بالكاميرات داخل
قاعه المحكمه وتصوير هذا الحدث التاريخي
القاضي اخوان مارشن المعروف عنه بالجديان
الكامله والحنك القانونيه في التعامل مع
قضاياه ولكن معروف ايضا بانسانيته
بالرغم ان الرئيس ترامب يقول انه هذا
القاضي يكرهه تماما ويحقد عليه سال
فريق محاميه ترامب وعارضه وجود اي كاميرات
داخل القاعه ولكن نفهم الان انه طلال
طلال
نعم
بعد ساعات من الان تفضل فقط فقدنا صوتك
قليلا اهلك كررت اخر فكره رجاء
نعم اقول ان القاضي سيتخذ قراره بالنسبه
لموضوع ادخال الكاميرات شركات الاعلام
والتلفزيون الامريكيه ومعها شركات كبرى
اجنبيه
طلبوا ان تدخل تدخل الكاميرات الى قاعه
المحكمه عندما يمثل الرئيس ترامب لاول مره
امام القاضي اخوان مرشان
لاستماع الى التهم المواجهه اليه هذا
القرار هو عاده هذا القاضي معروف عنه انه
لا يحب الكاميرات داخل القاعه ولكنه سيتخذ
قراره الليله وسنسمع فيما اذا يمكننا رؤيه
الرئيس ترامب يقف متهما امام القضاء
الامريكي في اعلى محكمه في جنائيه في داخل
منهات ام لا نرجو ان يكون الوضع كذلك لان
هذا تاريخ يجب يجب الحفاظ عليه نعم طيب
تنضم الان الينا في هذه التغطيه مديره
مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه بلبيسي
ناديه انت امام
حيث سيصل موكب الرئيس دونالد ترامب اذا
بعد وصوله قبل قليل اذا الى المطار على
متن طائرته الخاصه من طراز بوينج سبعه
خمسه سبعه الموكب الان في الطريق نحن
نتابع الصور المباشره وصولا الى هناك ما
هي الصوره عندك هل هناك اي تجمعات كذلك
لانصار دونالد ترامب الذين يتحضرون لمثوله
امام القاضي غدا
حيث اقف انا صهيب لا ارى اي تجمع لمؤيدي
الرئيس ترامب لكن ارى تجمعات للناس
العاديين يعني عدا الصحفيين الذين ينتشرون
عبر فيرس افينيو خلفي هناك عدد بالفعل بدا
يتجمع من المواطنين العاديين من السياح
وغيرهم ينتظرون وصول الرئيس والبعض ربما
يريد ان يلتقط صوره له على الاقل لهذا
الموكب اذا لم تكن للرئيس ترامب لكنه سيصل
خلال فتره وجيزه الى هنا وسيبقى في برج
توم هذا المكان الذي عقد فيه صفقات تجاريه
وكون حياته الماليه وكان بيته لسنوات بل
لعقود طويله حجر هذه الولايه وذهب الى
ولايه فلوريدا بعد الانتخابات
وطبعا سيلتقي مع محاميه سيكون هناك
مشاورات البعض يرى بانه القاضي نفسه قد
يطلب من ترامب الا يتحدث بشكل علني لكن
ترامب كما هو معروف استبق حتى قرار القاضي
واعلن عبر تروس ميديا واخبرنا جميعا بانه
سيلقي خطاب للشعب الامريكي لمؤيديه
لمناصريه ليله الثلاثاء يعني بمجرد خروجي
من المحكمه سيتجه الى مطار لاجواديا سيذهب
الى بان بيتش في فلوريدا وسيستريح لساعات
ثم سيلقي خطابا في ساعه الذروه في الساعه
الثامنه تقريبا او قرابه الثامنه وربع
بالتوقيت المحلي ليقول بان هذه
محاكمه تعصفيه بان هذه الاجراءات ظالمه
ومسيسه والى غيرها نعم ناديه وعطفا على ما
تقولين ترامب كان قد غرد قبل صعوده الى
الطائره متوجها من مقر اقامته في مراراغو
فلوريدا الى نيويورك كتب على منصه تروس
سوشل قبل دقائق من اقلاع الطائره عند
الواحده ظهرا قال انه متجه الى نيويورك
فلنجعل امريكا عظيمه مجددا واضاف ترامب في
تغريده اخرى هذه الحمله حمله اضطهاد
دولتنا التي كانت عظيمه في يوم من الايام
تتجه الى الجحيم كما يقول الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب كما نتابع معك المشهد في
نيويورك كذلك ناديه الشرطه في نيويورك
وضعت في حاله تاهب قبل مثوله ترامب امام
المحكمه ما الذي تخشاه الشرطه تحديدا
الذي تخشاه هو ان تتحول المسيرات او
التظاهرات السلميه المعارضه والمؤيده
للرئيس الى مواجهه واشتباكات ربما بين
الطرفين او حتى اشتباكات مع الشرطه او حتى
محاوله الهجوم على المحكمه يعني الذين
يؤيدون الرئيس يعني يؤيدونه بشكل اعمى
وهناك جماعات دخلت السجن على فكره وتم من
الجماعات التي تسمى باليمين المتطرف او
نقاء العنصر الابيض الذين كانوا يؤيدوا
ترامب في احداث السادس من يناير تم توجيه
تهم لهم باقتحام مبنى الكابيتال وطبعا كان
هناك اشخاص توفوا قتلوا في احداث
الكابيتال احداث الكونغرس فبالتالي تخشع
الشرطه ان يكون بالفعل هناك مواجهه لذا هي
تاخذ كل الاجراءات والتدابير الاحترازيه
لمنع اي اشتباك وطبع
ا على الصوره حيث انت في في نيويورك عدسات
الكاميرات اذا مسلطه على الموكب الذي يصل
الان على ما يبدو موكب الرئيس دونالد
ترامب ناديه عذرا اذا كنت تسمعينني لاحتج
[موسيقى]
على الرئيس ناديه اذا نحن نتابع وصول اذا
موكب الرئيس دونالد ترامب الى برج ترامب
بالفعل اذا طبعا معززا بتعزيزات امنيه
كذلك عدسات صحفيين
مسلطه اذا على المدخل الرئيسي
لبرج ترامب والشارع المؤدي اليه اذا في
نيويورك كما نتابع معكم في هذه الصور
المباشره طبعا ترامب كان استقل طائرته
الخاصه
في رحله دامت حوالي ساعتين ونصف باتجاه
نيويورك هذه الان عدسه العربيه اذا من
زاويه اخرى كذلك ووصول
الموكب موكب رئيس دونالد ترامب من المطار
اذا ووصوله الى برج ترامب او ترامب حيث
سيقيم هذه الليله قبل ان يمثل غدا امام
قاضي محكمه الجنايات في منهات
طبعا اذا هذه هي الصور نحن نتابع اذا
هناك فريق من مساعدي ترامب اذا ينزلون من
سيارات الموكب اذا باتجاه
المدخل الرئيسي تاور
اذا نحن مشاهدينا معكم في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه لوصول الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي سيقف غدا امام قاضي
محكمه الجنايات في منهاتن حيث تفتح امامه
لائحه الاتهامات التي تقول التسريبات
بانها تشمل 34 اتهاما ها هو دونالد ترامب
اذا نتابعه الان وهو يحيي اذا الصحفيين
وطبعا مجموعه من المحتشدين امام المدخل هو
دخل بسرعه اذا لم يتوقف كثيرا دخل اذن
بسرعه ونشاهد كذلك مجموعه من فريقه الامني
ومساعده كذلك مع رئيس الامريكي السابق اذا
هم يدخلون الى
برج ترامب او ترامب مقر اقامته الذي كان
رئيسيا حيث عاش في هذا المبنى لعقود
وسنوات طويله عندما بنى ثروته كذلك
واعماله كذلك هناك في نيويورك اذن الان
وصل الرئيس دونالد ترامب الى مقر اقامته
في نيويورك قاد ده رحله استمرت حوالي
ساعتين ونصف على متن طائرته الخاصه طائره
البوينج غدا سيمثل امام القاضي وسيفك
الشمع الاحمر عن لائحه الاتهامات التي
تقول التسريبات انها تشمل حوالي 34 اتهاما
طبعا اتهامات متعلقه
بقضيه دفعه مبلغ 130 الف دولار امريكي
لممثله الافلام الاباحيه
دانييلز
لاسكاتها عن البوح بتفاصيل علاقه جمعته
معها خارج اطار الزواج طبعا واسكاتها خلال
حملتها الانتخابيه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في الفين وسته عشر اذا هذا هو المشهد
الاذان الان من ترامب تاور ترامب اذا وصل
الى مقر اقامته هناك معنا الان من واشنطن
بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي بشار
نحن نتابع معك كذلك مجموعه من اللافتات
التي ترفع من قبل مؤيدي ترامب الان على
الشارع ترامب 2014
فيما يبدو اذا هو رساله تاييد من مؤيدي
ترامب
للرئاسه في الانتخابات المقبله سيد بشار
المعركه قضائيه
وقانونيه في نيويورك ولكنها معركه سياسيه
بامتياز في العاصمه واشنطن هل تعتقد ان
محاكمه ترامب هي لصالحه ام ضده في
انتخابات 2024
طبعا صهيب من خلال التغطيه الاعلاميه التي
عرضتموها هذه لا تكون مقترنه الا بحدث
ينال اهتمام ليس امريكي وطني فقط هذا حدث
عالمي هذه سابقه في تاريخ امريكا ان يقدم
ليس فقط رئيس سابق الى المحاكمه وانما
مرشح قبل اربعه اشهر فقط من اول مناظره
للفرز بين المرشحين على الحزب الجمهوري
هذه محاكمه هي اضطهاد سياسي بكل معنى كلمه
لانها من التسميات التي اعلنت عنها بانها
هي قضيه حاولوا بعثها من الاموات مر عليها
وحتى التقادم يعني يطبق عليها قانون سقوط
بالتقادم لان هذه القضيه ليست فقط قديمه
من سبع سنوات وانما ايضا اتخذ القرار
القضائي الخاص بها وهي انها غير صالحه لان
ينظر بها لا يوجد لها مارس بمعنى ولكن اذا
كان الوضع كذلك
استاذ بشار لماذا تم تفجيرها الان
تفجيرها لان هذا المدعي العام يا عزيزي
يعتقدون ان هكذا الاصلاح وهذا المدعي
العام
قال وتفاخر بانه سيتصدى وانه سيوقع
والعجيب في الامر انه قبل ايام من القرار
النهائي كانت هناك محاوله
للتاجيل ربما لشهر كامل بسبب الخلافات
التي اعترض الذين بحثوا هذا القرار الان
معروف في الثقافه الامريكيه عزيزي انك
عندما تحيل قضيه الى هيئه محلفين تستطيع
مقاضاه ما يسمى باللغه الانجليزيه
لحم خنزير يعني
بانك بيكن ساندويتش تستطيع انت ان عرضت
على هيئه محلفين لديها بعض النوازع
السياسيه ان تدين هذه السندويش بالقيام
باعمال كبيره مخالفه للقانون هي المشكله
ولكن ماذا لو ثبت استاذ بشار يعني عمليا
مدعيا هو يقوم بعمله يعني اذا كان
بعيدا عن القضيه الاخلاقيه مساله انه دفع
هذه الاموال من ممولي حمله ترامب او من
الاموال التي من المفترض ان توجه لصالح
العام هو استخدمها لدفعها لممثله اباحيه
حتى لا تفصح عن علاقه جمعتها معه يعني الا
يمكن ان يكون هذه قضيه بالفعل مهمه
بالنسبه لمن يصوت لصالحه الناخب الامريكي
حفيظه الطرف الذي قال كيف نثق بمدعي عام
من هذا الوزن القضيه الاخرى حتى من ناحيه
القانونيه عزيزي
في المعنيه في الموضوع وقعت اقرارا بانه
لا صح انها اقامت اي علاقه مع ترامب
الموضوع كان ابتزاز وقضيه الخشمني او شراء
الصمت هذه ليست سابقاوم
تورط بها بابلو جونز تورط بها
عن الحزب الديمقراطي ايضا قضيه ايضا النظر
اي محكمه تنظر الان
هناك من الفريق القانوني لترامب بان تنقل
خارج منهاجا لان حتى القاضي وكما ذكر يعني
مراسلكم القاضي هناك لديه انطباع الرئيس
ترامب بانه
فهناك من يكون قضيه اذا اذا كانت في
القضيه برمتها مساله تفجير هذه القضيه
الان هي في اطار المكيده السياسيه هل
معقول الا يدرك الحزب الديمقراطي او
الديمقراطيون ومدعي عام منهات بانه هنا هو
يقدم خدمه لترامب يستثمرها انتخابيا
عزيزه انا لست مع نظريات المؤامره ولكن لا
تماما نحن نعلم خاصه في الشك الاوسط لدينا
مشكله مع قضيه نظريه المؤامره ولكن هناك
من يقول وهذا راي وازن بان الحزب
الديمقراطي لا يملك فرصه
لان ينجح في الانتخابات المقبله الا اذا
كان المنافس هو ترامب هم يريدون ترامب
تحديدا وبالتالي يريدون دفع هذا السباق
الذي الان يزاحم عليه وان كان بفرق الضعف
يريدون هنا هنا او وصلتني الى سؤال هل
ترامب الان مع هذه القضيه
تكون حظوظه اكثر ام اقل كي يرشح من قبل
الحزب الجمهوري خاصه مع ارتفاع شعبيه
دسانتس
مع اخي صهيب لان النسبه الضعف اولا ثانيا
سابقه في تاريخ الحملات الانتخابيه في اقل
من 48 ساعه جمع اربع ملايين دولار المهم
ليس فقط في هذا الرقم المهم ان المعدل
الخاص به هو 38 دولار بمعنى ان القاعده
الشعبيه تتحرك الان ليس فقط الجمهوريين
يعني صدقني انا شخصيا ومن اثق بهم كان
هناك نقاش انه لماذا نصر على ترامب قد
تكون الفرصه مواجهه اكثر لطرح شخصيه جامعه
للحزب واقل صداميه ولكن ما قاموا بفعل
عمليا هو اضطهاد سياسي على كل امريكا وطني
قبل ان يكون جمهوري او ديمقراطي ان يتصدى
لهذه الظاهره التي اسموها جعلوا من امريكا
للاسف جمهوريه موز طيب تعليقا فقط على ما
يدور الان في نيويورك بايدن يعلق على
احتمال اندلاع اعمال عنف اثناء محاكمه
ترامب يقول انه يثق في شرطه نيويورك عاجل
على شاشه العربيه الى ان نتابعها اسفل
الشاشه اذا طبعا هذا مشاهدينا مع انتشار
حوالي اكثر من 30 الف شرطه في نيويورك
استعدادا لمثوله الرئيس ترامب غدا امام
القاضي استاذ بشار اشكرك على هذه المداخله
معنا في هذه التغطيه وانتم باقون معنا
اضافه الى الزملاء ناديه وطلال من نيويورك
لمتابعه اذن هذه الاحداث اذا مشاهدينا
نتابع معكم
التغطيه اذا في اخبار الساعه خبر الساعه
اذا هو وصول دونالد ترامب قبل قليل كما
تبعنا معكم الى مقر اقامته في نيويورك
قادما من فلوريدا على متن طائرته الخاصه
شاهدناه مرتين
قد كتب على منصه تروس سوشل المفضله
بالنسبه اليه بانه قادم الى نيويوركا يجعل
امريكا عظيمه مجددا شعره في حملته
الانتخابيه وشاهدناه معكم وهو يصل الى مقر
اقامه نشاهد الان حشدا من مؤيديه مؤيديه
الذين يخشى منهم ان يكرروا السيناريو
اقتحام مبنى الكونغرس واحدث الكابيتول في
السادس يناير 2021 عندما لم يعترف ترامب
بخسارته في الانتخابات الرئاسيه امام جو
بايدن واعتبر انها انتخابات
مزوره نشاهد ترامبون ترامب ربح في هذه
اللافته التي يرفعها احد المؤيدين طبعا من
احد مؤيديها الان في في نيويورك الشارع
المقابل او في حيث يقع برج ترامب حيث
سيقيم هذه الليله طبعا الشرطه في نيويورك
هي تتاهب لاحتماليه حدوث اعمال عنف من قبل
مؤيدي
على العموم سنبقي اعيننا على كل تطورات
الموقف هناك بانتظار مثول الرئيس ترامب
غدا امام قاضي المحكمه الجنائيه في
مشاهدينا منذ ان اعلن او اعلن عن ملاحقه
الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد ترامب بقضايا
جنائيه وماليه برزت عده اسماء مؤثره في
هذه القضيه نتابع ابرزها في التالي
ابرز شخصيات المحاكمه التاريخيه دونالد
ترامب الرئيس الامريكي السابق يواجه لائحه
باكثر من 30 اتهاما بقضايا ماليه وجنائيه
[موسيقى]
اسمها الحقيقي ستيفاني كليفورت تزعم انها
كانت في علاقه مع ترامب قبل ان يشتري
صمتها مايكل كوهن محامي ترامب السابق تحول
لشاهد ادعاء رئيسي ضد ترامب
الفنبراج مدعي عاما هاتن اول من قدم لائحه
الاتهام ضد ترامب
خوان ميرشن قاضي المحكمه العليا في
نيويورك عين للاشراف على هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى
ومشاهدي معكم في متابعه خبر الساعه وهي
السابقه تاريخيه ان يمثل رئيس امريكي سابق
امام محكمه جنائيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نتابع ايضا مع شبكه مراسلينا
اذا من امام برج ترامب في نيويورك مديره
مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ومن امام محكمه
نيويورك في منهات كبير المراسلين طلال
الحاج طلال اسالك هنا قبل قليل بايدن قال
انه يثق في شرطه نيويورك الحديث هنا عن
احتماليه حدوث اعمال عنف وبدانا نشاهد بعض
المؤيدين لدونالد ترامب هل هناك
احتماليه كبيره لتكرار سيناريو احدث
الكابيتول غدا مع مثول ترامب امام القاضي
ان يتم تكرار السيناريو اقتحام مبنى
الكونغرس لاسباب مختلفه اولا في ذلك الوقت
كان هناك عشرات الالاف للمؤيدي الرئيس
الذين اتوا من كل الولايات المتحده وكان
الهدف هو عدم الاقرار بشرعيه الانتخابات
وبالتالي كانت لديهم من وجهه نظري فرصه في
بالفعل بان يكون الرئيس ترامب هو رئيس
الولايات المتحده لكن الان نتحدث عن
اتهامات وجهت له بسبب علاقه مع ممثله
اباحيه هم يدافعون عن الرئيس وليس عن قضيه
بهذا المعنى لذا لا اتوقع بان يكون العدد
مشابه لما كان في واشنطن في احداث
الكابيتال الان بدانا نرى بوصول الرئيس
الى
راينا بالفعل عدد عشرات من مناصرهم
ومؤيدين يحملون لافتات كتب عليها ترامب 20
وطلبوا منه بناء الحائط وهي اشاره الى ما
كان يكرره الرئيس دوما بالنسبه لبناء حائط
مع المكسيك في الحدود الجنوبيه لبناء تدفق
المهاجرين لكن الشرطه تضبط الوضع حاليا
وهناك انتشار كثيف لها على لقب هنا في
طيب على العموم السؤال هو كان لزميل طلال
ولكن كلنا فريق واحد طبعا وطلال هنا اعود
اليك طبعا يعود وينضم الينا في التغطيه
الاستاذ بشار جرار كذلك الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ولكن هنا طلال اسالك كذلك عن
المحكمه كذلك هذا حول اقامه اطلعتنا نادي
على الصوره هناك
واحتشاد انصار ترامب ماذا عن محيط المحكمه
ماذا ننتظره كذلك من انصار ترامب غدا
ليس اليوم ولكن في الغد كما تفضلت صهيب
نتوقع اعداد كبيره اعداد كبيره من
المناصريه ترامب ان يقدموا الى هذه
الحديقه الصغيره وستحاوطهم الشرطه بكل
تاكيد ولكن يخشون هنا سواء المواطنين
القاطنين في هذا
نعم طلال تفضل
طيب هناك مشكله في الصوت على ما يبدو
وهناك ايضا فارق زمني بيننا وبين نيويورك
في الصوت على العموم نحن نتابع اذا الان
الحدث هو يبقى في نيويورك ونشاهد الان
مجموعه من المؤيدين لترامب هنا نشاهد
لافته تطالب باعتقال بايدن يرفعها احد
المؤيدين لدونالد ترامب اريست بايدن كما
نشاهد معكم اذا التجمع كبير للصحفيين طبعا
المكان هنا هو بالقرب من ترامبور او برج
ترامب حيث مقر اقامه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب هناك في نيويورك وكان
مقر اقامته منذ عقود قبل ان ينتقل الى
فلوريدا هو يعود اليه فقط الليله سيبيت
هناك ويمثل غدا امام القاضي امام المحكمه
الجنائيه في سابقه تاريخيه ان يمثل رئيس
امريكي سابق امام محكمه
لابلاغه رسميا بالتوجيه تهم جنائيه اليه
في قضيه دفع اموال لنجمه افلام اباحيه
لشراء صمتها في حدث غير مسبوق الحقيقه
مشاهدينا لرئيس امريكي سابق كنا تبعنا
معكم وصول الطائره الخاصه التي اقلت ترامب
من مطار لغوارديا من فلوريدا بعد رحله
استمرت ساعتين ونصف الى نيويورك على
العموم نذهب الى بشار جرار الكاتب السياسي
سؤال ايضا هنا عن مناصريه ترامب الى اي حد
يخشى من تكرار سيناريو احدث الكابيتول
تعلمنا الدرس
اعتقد من الخبر او الحدث ولكن اقصد بذلك
تعلمنا كيف يتم توظيف بعض الاحداث لغايات
تختطف حزبيا هذا الامر لم يحدث فقط في
احداث سته يناير حدث نحو سافر واكثر خطوره
ابدال قضيه
وجدنا كيف قضيه اعتقال لشخص ثبت ان في
جسمه دمائهم مشبعه في المخدر
تحولت الى قضيه ابيض واسود وتحولت الى
قضيه اضطهاد اقليات ووجدنا كيف ان هذا
الموضوع شكل بشكل او باخر نوع من التغيير
في عقليه الناخب الام
ريكي وجدنا كيف تم تصعيد هذه
القضيه كان الذي يؤيد الت
رامب تجدد
هذا كما قالت
الاستاذه ناديه قبل قليل بالفعل لا مؤيدي
ترامب ولا اي حتى بالمطلق اي امريكي معني
بالشان العام مستعد ان يضع نفسه في هذا
الموقف هذه الشبهه بانه يريد ان يثير اي
اعمال عنف لان المستفيد سيكون هم خصومه
ترامب وهذه القضيه ليست بالقضيه الكبرى
كما كانت الحال بالسناير انها
هي هي سابقه تاريخيه كما ذكرت عذرا على
المقاطعه ان يمثل الرئيس امريكي سابق صحيح
هو سابق امام محكمه جنائيه ماذا لو ادين
في احدى التهم التي ستوجه اليه غدا
حتى طبعا سؤال افتراضي ولكن انا شخصيا
مقتنع انه قطعا لن يتم ذلك الان السؤال هو
هل سيتم رفض الاخذ بالقضيه من اساسها
بمعنى انها ستسقط في المراسلات حتى قبل ان
يتم اعتبارها بان قضيه صالحه للادعاء اما
انها ستصل الى مرحله ان الموضوع يتطلب
نوعه من المحاكمه حتى هذا ثمن اعداد له
وتم الكشف عنه بان هناك من سيطرح قضيه ان
منهات غير مؤهله لان تكون ساحه لهذا
النزاع القضائي ويستم الانتقال الى مقاطع
اخرى في مدينه نيويورك الامريكيه اقل عداء
واقل عداء للجمهوريه لا يعقل يا عزيزي
بالمنطق من هاتم لم يحصل فيها الرئيس رب
الا 1% من الاصوات كيف يكون منطقيا ان تجد
هيئه محلفين ومن الواضح هذه الهيئه انها
ضد ترامب ضد الجمهوريين ضد المحيط دعني
اسال طلال هو امام المحكمه الجنائيه في
منهاتن طلال ماذا نعرف عن لائحه الاتهامات
التي هي مختومه بالشمع الاحمر وسيتم فك
هذا الشمع غدا عنها وعرضها امام المتهم
دونالد ترامب باختصار لو سمحت
نعم كل ما نعرفه انها اكثر من 30 تهمه
ونفهم فهمنا من مصادر اخرى انها اربع اربع
وثلاثون تهمه بالتحديد
كلها متعلقه ببزنس فروج اي احتيال في مجال
الاعمال عندما دفع ترامب الاموال لمحاميه
مايكل حين ذلك
لتعويضه عن المبالغ التي دفعها الى
130 الف دولار ووضعها في سجل الشركه بانها
اتعاب استشارات قانونيه هو هذا الاحتيال
الذي يحاكم بسببه وهي جنحه في معظم
الاوقات جنحه يغرم على شخص مبلغ
صغير الا ان في نيويورك هناك قانون يسمح
بتحويل الجنحه الى جنايه اذا كانت تخفي
وراءها جريمه ناديه اعود اليك انت امام
برج ترامب لاحظنا
وصول الرئيس الانف طائرته الخاصه طبعا
وكان هناك موكب كبير عمليا مجموعه كبيره
من الحراس ومن المستشارين كذلك ماذا نعرف
عن من يرافق ترامب في هذه الرحله رحله
متوليه امام القضاء فريق المحامين كذلك
مما يتكون كل هذه التفاصيل المتعلقه بمثول
الرئيس السابق في سابق تاريخيه امام
المحكمه غدا
صهيب بانه فريق صغير جدا يضم حوالي ثلاثه
من مستشاريه وربما عدد من المحامين الذين
يرافقون في هذه الرحله وبالتالي سيقضي
الرئيس وقتا معهم وقد يطلبوا منه على فكره
بان لا يتحدث للاعلام من الان وبعد او حتى
قراءه التهم الموجهه له كنا نقول في
المداخله السابقه بان القاضي قد يطلب من
الرئيس بعدم الحديث عن القضيه لكن طبعا
رمز سبق ذلك وطلب عبر توس ميديا من
متابعيه ان يستمعوا له في هذا الخطاب غدا
ليله الثلاثاء لكن اريد ان اقول ايضا
باننا قبل قليل كان هناك عاده عن الموكب
الكبير الذي تحدثت عنه والشرطه السريه
كانت هناك طائرات مروحيه تحلق في سماء
الامور في منهات بالقرب من تروم تاور انا
اتواجد وهناك ايضا عدد للشرطه التي بدات
تحيط في هذا المكان عشرات من رجال الشرطه
الذين يتحركون في كل اتجاه عدا عن مئات من
الصحفيين الذين يرصدون كل حركه للرئيس على
امل ربما ان يخرج من تاور او انه سيبقى في
هذا المكان حتى
ذهابي طوعي الى المحكمه منتصف
ظهر غدا الثلاثاء نعم بعد العصر غدا او
عصر الغد سيذهب سينتقل ترامبيون من مقر
اقامته الى مقر المحكمه في منهات اذا
سنكتفي بهذا القدر معكم شكرا جزيلا على
هذه التغطيه الوافيه اذا مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي من امام
برج ترامب ومن امام محكمه نيويورك
الجنائيه في منهاتن كبير المراسلين طلال
الحاج والشكر الموصول لك ايضا عبر سكايب
الاستاذ بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
مشاهدين ننتقل بعدها الى اخبار الرياضه
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
واخبار الساعه انتهت وكان فيها الحقيقه
خبر ساعه وحيد خبر الساعه كان وصول ترامب
الى نيويورك
ودخوله الى مقر اقامته في ترامب تاور حيث
سيمضي هذه الليله
ويمثل غدا امام قاضي محكمه منهاتن
الجنائيه في سابقه تاريخيه في قضيه طبعا
دفعه اموالا لاسكات ممثله الافلام
الاباحيه شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]